There are 168 different currencies in the
world and billions of dollars worth on new
banknotes are printed every day across the
world.
Here's some of the most amazing facts about
money.
1.
Before coins were invented in 1500 BC, people
used to trade in all kinds of strange commodities,
such as gold, rice, fish, barley, salt, tea
leaves, cows, blood, and even bat guano.
In America the word "buck" to mean money comes
from the days when people used to trade various
animal skins, including buckskins as currency.
2.
The art of making money is precise and complex.
Each coin has to be exactly the same as the
next, so that people accept that they are
worth the same amount of money.
Traditionally coins were made by either striking
metal between two engraved dies, or by casting
them in moulds.
However in the 18th century coins were made
by new steam powered machinery, which greatly
increased the number of coins that could be
produced in a day.
3.
The production of bank notes however is a
bit money complicated.
Originally bank notes were black and white
but now almost all of them are brightly coloured
and feature highly complex designs, which
makes them harder to counterfeit but also
instantly recognisable as a national currency.
4.
In 1923, hyperinflation caused German currency
to lose almost all of its value.
It became so worthless that people gave it
to children to play with or even used it as
wallpaper.
5.
India has a banknote of zero value.
They look exactly the same as other banknotes
but are worth exactly zero rupees.
You might ask, what's the point?
Corruption in India is widespread and a major
concern.
Many government officials in India require
monetary bribes for all sorts of permits and
services.
The zero rupee banknote serves an important
purpose, it is given to officials who request
bribes as a statement of peaceful non-cooperation.
Each zero rupee note bares a declaration that
states "I promise to neither accept nor give
a bribe".
It's sole purpose is to make a statement.
Ironically this makes the zero rupee banknote
both valuable and worth absolutely nothing
at the same time.
6.
In most countries and currencies one pence
pieces cost more money to make than they are
actually worth.
The US treasury spends 2.41 cents to mint
each penny, making a huge loss.
Because of this the Canadian government stopped
producing pennies in 2013.
7.
The world's largest counterfeiter of US currency
is North Korea.
They produce high quality fakes that the American
Secret Service have nicknamed "superdollars"
because they so closely resemble genuine notes.
8.
The production of banknotes requires zero
trees, no paper is used at all.
All paper currency is made from a custom blend
of cotton and linen, usually around 25% cotton
and 75% linen.
9.
90% of US banknotes contain traces of cocaine.
10.
Queen Elizabeth II is the queen of currency,
her portrait has graced the currencies of
33 different countries, more than any other
individual in history.
Canada was the first country to use the British
monarch's portrait on their banknotes in 1935,
when it printed the, at the time, 9-year-old
princess on its $20 notes.
11.
More monopoly money is printed every year
than real money.
12.
If you have just $10 in your pocket and no
debts, you are wealthier than 25% of Americans.
13.
A cheque is only an instruction to a bank,
it therefore, can be written on absolutely
anything, and as long as it has all the necessary
components, it will be honoured by the bank.
Cheques have been written on doors, stone
slabs, bananas and even cows.
14.
Banknotes are pretty gross.
A study showed that 14% of banknotes contain
fecal matter and 94% contain pathogens.
Viruses and bacteria can live on most surfaces
for about 48 hours, but they can live on paper
money for up to 17 days.
15.
Icelanders pay for things using credit and
debit cards more than any other country in
the world.
70% of all business in Iceland is done with
plastic, compared to 39% in North America.
16.
Australia makes its banknotes from Polymer,
which is a type of synthetic plastic.
They last for 2.5 times longer than traditional
cotton and linen banknotes and are surprisingly
more eco friendly.
They are also harder to counterfeit.
The UK will also be switching to plastic banknotes
in 2016.
17.
Some coins have grooved ridges around their
edges.
They serve little purpose today, but they
were originally added in the days when coins
were made from precious metals such as silver
and gold.
People used to scrape the edges off the coins
before spending them, then sell the precious
metals they scraped off.
The grooved ridges were added to stop people
doing this.
18.
A vast majority of the money in the world
is not physical money, it is simply numbers
in the computers of banks.
19.
Money which cannot be backed by a physical
commodity such as gold is called Fiat money.
Fiat money includes digital funds, paper banknotes
and coins, these kinds of money are only valuable,
simply because a government declares it an
official currency.
However other non-government backed fiat money
can become valuable, just because there's
a high demand for it, such as the emerging
Bitcoin currency, which has no centralised
control body.
The only thing that makes Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies valuable is the simple fact
that lots of people want it.
20.
And finally, if all the gold in the world
were melted down into a single square block,
it would only be 21 metres on each side.